il y a fort longtemps un peuple existait
et se nourrissaient de temps passé à
regarder des vidéos on les appelait in
youtube bien
[Musique]
cependant un jour la nourriture de ce
peuple commençait à devenir empoisonné
des vidéos en fermant mensonge titre
trompeur et usurpation youtube
périssaient chaque jour passé et les
seuls vidéo apportant un minimum
nutritifs étaient les vidéos musicales y
c'est alors qu'un jour un jeune vidéaste
apparu en théoricien voyant youtube
dépérir il sama du lay en force
son symbole de force et de courage et
créa une vidéo si travail et qu'elle fût
première des tendances youtube et donc
terrassa les vidéos empoisonné le mal
était alors vaincu et même si la
bataille fait encore rage aujourd'hui le
jeune vidéaste redonna l'espoir et
nombreux sont les vidéastes qui l'ont
rejoint pour combattre ce fléau
le leinster ce fut alors une divinité
crier partout les youtube bien ce
symbole avait ramené la féliciter
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une licence qui me
passionne autant voire plus que star
wars c'est bien the legend of zelda
c'est une saga que j'ai torché mon
pseudo vient même de cette dernière et
après avoir passé plus de 150 heures sur
zelda brasse of the wild je me devais de
faire un trois théories sur ce
chef-d'oeuvre
je tiens à remercier mon ami est très
bon vidéaste graff yam pour la voix off
de l'intro si vous souhaitez apprendre
des choses sur les jeux nintendo je vous
conseille sa chaîne qui est en
descriptions c'était donc normal que je
l'invite pour une vidéo théorie sur
zelda
bref du très lourd vous êtes en niveau
théorie avec un bon 80% de subjectif
dedans allez c'est parti
[Musique]
bon parlons de la question qui fâche et
que tout le monde attend donc autant
commencer par celle ci où se trouve
zelda breath of the whale dans la
timeline zelda je vais répondre
personnellement la question car je me
suis beaucoup intéressé ces derniers
temps tout d'abord résumons la timeline
très rapidement l'histoire se passe on
arrive à ocarina of time l'épisode clés
de la timeline zelda
voilà c'était rapide mais attendez ce
n'est pas fini la timeline scoop donc
ensuite en trois parties la première
suit l'histoire de l'hymne qui retourna
dans le passé ont renvoyé par zelda
après le combat final contre lugano dans
ocarina of time afin qu'il puisse
avertir le royaume avant que la calamité
n'intervienne ganondorf sera alors jugé
et cetera et cetera
ceci ne nous intéresse pas réellement si
vous voulez que je fasse une vidéo sur
la timeline zelda dites le moi en
commentaire ensuite la dernière et
troisième partie suit l'histoire du
royaume d'hyrule
après que link est été renvoyé dans le
passé car oui le présent a tout de même
continuer à perdurer même céline qui a
été renvoyé dans le passé pour le
changer ce qui me semble logique mais
ganondorf est revenu plusieurs fois
mettre un sacré bazar
et voilà comment ça j'ai oublié une
partie non je sais je les fais exprès
car c'est celle ci qui nous intéresse
car d'après moi zelda breath of the wild
se situerait dans la timeline du milieu
celle que je n'ai pas encore annoncé où
link est supposé perdre contre gan dans
karina of time
cette timeline est assez morbide c'est
la fêlure timeline ou link a perdu et où
le royaume d'hyrule et ravagé pour la
plupart du temps pour moi a breath of
the wild se situerait à la toute fin de
celle ci
juste après zelda 2 pourquoi
premièrement ce zelda est obligé d'être
placé en dernier et ce peu importe la
timeline car c'est un zelda futuriste la
technologie et la modernité sont très
mise en avant surtout par la création de
gardiens soient de machines ce qui est
contraire à tous ses prédécesseurs qui
reste assez moyenâgeux même s'il avait
été placé après spirit tracks dans la
timeline de l'adulte
cela aurait été impossible car c'est un
tout nouveau hyrule qui est créé et qui
n'a pas les moyens de créer les gardiens
et les créatures divines
pareil pour la suite de force wars
adventures ou dans cette timeline
d'échec à sont quasi inexistants comme
dans la première timeline après tout
bref là n'est pas la question
un point important en rajouter et que
aonuma le créateur de zelda breath of
the wild a confirmé que l'opus se
déroulait bien après ocarina of time ce
qui est évident il n'y a qu'à voir
certains détails du jeu
pour moi ce zelda breath of the white se
situerait suite à zelda 2 dans la figure
timeline maintenant quelles bases nous
donne ce breath of the wild
la malédiction faisant revenir ganon
existe toujours et le sera à jamais
cependant suite aux combats victorieux
face à la bête il n'y a plus de dix
mille ans le peuple pris connaissance
d'une ancienne magie sheika et la
création des gardiens et des créatures
divines firent leur apparition dans le
but d'aider le héros et lui des déesses
à vaincre ganon à l'avenir c'est alors
que ganon réapparu dix mille ans avant
brest of the wild et fut combattu et
scellée par link avec l'aide des
gardiens et des créatures divines sans
énormément de mal cependant ayant appris
de ses erreurs la calamité ganon refit
surface s'entend avant breath of the
wild est il pris contrôle des gardiens
et des créatures divines et ravagea le
royaume zelda réussi à placer tant bien
que mal link dans le sanctuaire de la
renaissance suite à son décès face à gan
le héros se réveille alors cent ans plus
tard dans un virulent ravagé et où il
doit sauver la princesse zelda bien
maintenant que pouvons-nous rajouter
tout d'abord la faille leur timeline est
une timeline ou l'ennemi est toujours
ganon et non guen dorff et le boss final
de zelda breath of the wild et bien
évidemment
la calamité ganon c'est la seule
timeline ou ganon est scellée sous cette
forme et donc réapparaissent où celle ci
à chaque fois car il se libère de plus
ganon et surpuissant je vous rappelle
qu'il a touché la triforce et possède
celle de la force dans karina of time se
serait d'ailleurs pourquoi ligne qui a
déjà perdu contre lui et où les
créatures divines serait apparue pour
l'épauler ainsi que les gardiens il a
déjà perdu deux fois contre ce dernier
ensuite la master sword l'épée de
légende que seul l'élu ddsp campagne est
situé dans le bois perdus et seulement
dans le link to the past un zelda
prédécesseur de breath of the oil située
dans la même timeline s'y trouve aussi
il y à même le détail des deux fleurs
qui reste tout de même assez important
d'ailleurs la map de link to the past
ressemble énormément à celle de breath
of the wild mais cela reste un détail
les sages sont une référence dans breath
of the wide puisque leurs noms sont
utilisés pour les créatures divines je
pense à vars uta qui évoque le nom de la
princesse au couteau ou bien vannes à
boris qui évoque la sage guérido none à
bochum et varrault dania qui évoque
d'arreau n'ya cependant jamais d'eau
pourrait symboliser medal in the wind
waker ce qui pourrait fausser la théorie
néanmoins peu sont les zelda possédant
le peuple piaf
il se pourrait que cela soit une simple
référence car les pierre de bresse off
the wall ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
que ceux de wind waker d'ailleurs breath
of the world a été confirmé qu'il
n'était pas la suite de wind waker cela
me rassure pour ma théorie mais bref
tout ceci pour vous dire que les sages
sont assez vénéré dans cette feuille
d'or timeline sans rentrer dans les
détails
puis enfin l'argument qui me fait
vraiment confirmer cette théorie
même si elle peut être fausse attention
vous n'avez pas l'impression de jouer à
un ancien jeu zelda avec une certaine
tunique
oui je parle bien évidemment de la tenue
des landes s'est tenue et la tenue
portée par tous les linke de la fêlure
timeline et c'est un argument clé cette
tenue est une récompense des sortes de
stages dans les sanctuaires soit de la
ds il y a suite à l'obtention de la
totalité des sanctuaires
c'est un cadeau de la ds pour avoir
réussi à braver chaque sanctuaire les
autres tenues comme celle du crépuscule
ne sont donnés que par les amis beau la
tenue des landes est une récompense
donnée par le jeu lui-même
tout ceci me laisse croire que zelda
breath of the whale se passerait durant
cette période
j'espère avoir été clair et que ma
théorie vous a plu j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps dit moi en commentaire en
attendant passons à la suite
[Musique]
un mystère est présent dans breath of
the wild et m'intrigue réellement j'ai
envie de vous parler de l'alfa appelé
aussi le sage ou la légende c'est une
monture légendaire que nous pourrons
capturés sur le mont satory nous pouvons
tout d'abord l'apercevoir grâce à une
grande lueur bleue verte
cependant ce cheval est un réel mystère
car l'alpha ne peut être enregistrée et
ce dans n'importe quels relais une
description apparaîtra disant que cette
créature sacré qu'elle alpha est la
réincarnation d'un stage décédé qui
veillent et protège ses terres je ne
vais pas vous le cacher plus longtemps
c'est une double théorie c'est à dire
qu'elle est possible pour un personnage
mais aussi un autre que nous allons voir
tout de suite dans le premier cas de
figure celui que je crois le plus
l'alpha légendaire serait le sage de la
lumière aux rues de zelda ocarina of
time rue et le sache calling rencontrera
suite à son réveil dans ocarina of time
il réside dans le sanctuaire des sages
et apparaît dans le jeu sous la forme de
game aura le hibou et dans link tout le
temps de son aventure
oui c'est confirmé dans hyrule historia
grippe aura et bien la réincarnation
d'euros rue tout cela pour vous dire
ruelle ligne tout le long de son
aventure dans ocarina of time et a pour
rôle d'être un sage soins défenseur et
un protecteur d'hyrule ce qui correspond
exactement à la description de l'alfa
réincarnation d'un sage décédé qui
veillent et protège ses terres
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire d'ocarina of
time rue est le plus ancien des sages
présent est le premier à connaître son
rôle de sage car les autres sages
devront être réveillé par link dans le
jeu rue a toujours eu ce rôle de
protection et nous le retrouvons dans la
description de la fal légendaire de plus
heureux est un personnage mort je vous
rappelle qu'aucun vivant à parler lui
des ds ne peut accéder aux sanctuaires
des sages la fin du jeu nous le prouve
avec l'absence de ce dernier dans le
générique
suite à la défaite de la bête ganon les
autres sages serait retournée dans leurs
peuples respectifs nabot ruche et les
guerres ou d'eau ou touche les au radar
ou n'y a chez les gorons et j'en passe
pour diriger leurs peuples et ou
retourner à leur fonction principale
hu et le seul sage à vivre seul et à
vivre en tant que sage il est le sage de
la lumière quand ganon fut vaincu la
mission fut donc accompli et se laissa
partir pour venir en tant qu alpha la
monture légendaire qui d'ailleurs se
cachent sur le monde satory situé à côté
à l'ouest d'hyrule sûrement dans le but
de garder un oeil bienveillant sur ce
dernier
enfin le fait que l'alpha et pour surnom
lesage nous montre bien la possibilité
de cette théorie et nous interroge même
sur cette évidence mais c'est le but
d'une théorie n'est ce pas alors est-ce
vrai ou tout simplement faux a vous de
me le dire dans les commentaires
néanmoins une autre théorie sur ce
cheval beaucoup plus connus fait surface
car oui la précédente était entre
guillemets imaginé par moi même l'alfa
légendaire serait l'ancien défunt
président de nintendo satoru iwata
alors oui un hommage lui est déjà rendu
avec le personnage de dos un lien qui
lui ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau
mais un hommage caché pourrait bien
existé
justement où des eaux est un personnage
étrangement lié à l'alpha tout d'abord
il est situé au relais de l'orée de la
plaine qui est le relais le plus proche
du monde satory de plus lorsque vous lui
parlez il vous donnera des informations
sur la monture légendaire l'alpha puis
c'est un détail mais qui prend tout de
même tout son sens
oudot est un hommage à l'ancien pdg qui
se nommait satoru iwata est l'alpha
légendaire est quant à lui situé au
monde satory savez besoin que
j'argumente plus ce moment est une
énorme référence rien que par son nom
d'ailleurs le personnage de dos et
bienveillant et avertit lynn que des
dangers de voyager seul dans hyrule
il s'inquiète pour lui et le met en
garde une référence à la protection et à
l' influence de satoru iwata au sein de
nintendo même qui s'occupait de ses
équipes dans l'entreprise mais aussi des
fans de la franchise ou d'eau serait
tout simplement le portail permettant de
comprendre l'hommage que les
développeurs ont rendu à leur ancien
patron
c'est une énigme à lui tout seul après
tout nous sommes dans l da iwata avait
supervisé le développement de breath of
the whale pendant un an ou deux avant sa
mort en 2015
les créateurs du jeu ont donc été très
affecté enfin l'alpha sur le mont satory
se trouve sous un cerisier un arbre
symbolisant l'immortalité et la destinée
dans la culture japonaise
l'alfa serait donc la réincarnation de
satoru iwata veillant sur les terre
d'hyrule mais aussi sur l'entreprise de
nintendo pour finir en beauté j'aimerais
parler des prochains dlc comme vous le
savez nintendo commence de plus en plus
à créer du contenu additionnel pour ses
jeux et zelda breath of the wild en
possédera donc un aussi un season pass
pour les prix d'une vingtaine d'euros
vous permettra d'obtenir du nouveau
contenu en juillet et en décembre 2010
est le premier contiendra un mode
difficile et le retour du défi de la
caverne de l'ordalie provenant de zelda
twilight princess
donc voilà rien de bien mystérieux
cependant pour le contenu additionnel de
décembre une nouvelle histoire sera donc
ajoutés ainsi qu'un nouveau donjon est
donc un nouveau boss c'est ce dlc qui
nous intéresse déjà ce contenu
additionnel n'est disponible qu'en
décembre
d'une part pour faire vivre le jeu
beaucoup plus longtemps mais aussi pour
nous montrer qu'il a fallu du temps pour
l'ajouter ce qui nous promet donc du
lourd mais que pourrait-il y avoir dans
ce dlc
laissons parler notre imagination il est
question d'un nouveau donjon les donjons
dans breath of the whale sont les
créatures divines chaque créature
correspond un peuple précis d'hyrule
varrault dania pour les gorons var où tu
as pour les zorra va m'aider pour les
piafs evans à boris pour léguer roudaut
vous allez me dire qu'il me manque les
îliens
cependant le donjon lien est le château
d'hyrule donc par élimination le dernier
temps peu seraient en rapport avec un
peuple peu connu je parle évidemment des
chèques a pour moi je verrais bien dlc
se passant dans le futur de l'histoire
de bressols the wild avec une nouvelle
créature divine appartenant aux tchèques
à koga en serait le prodige le chef du
gang liga lady gaga aurait alors le
contrôle de cette nouvelle créature pour
se venger de ligne qui a vaincu koga
justement c'est un peuple qui prêtent
allégeance à kanon et souhaite la mort
de tous ceux qui s'y opposent dont l'élu
damman c'est une option ou bien un
retour du temple de l'ombre un temple en
rapport avec les shekau nombreux de ces
derniers ont souffert là bas je parle
beaucoup des ieg a car justement l'échec
à sont peu mis en avant le sort passe of
the wild
d'après la théorie du génocide d'hyrule
ou les îliens en massacrer les chèques à
à paris mme pas dans le temple de
l'ombre les liga soit l'échec à se
vengerait donc de cette trahison
ce serait pourquoi ils se sont ralliés à
ganon le fléau links parcours est alors
ce temple et en apprendrez plus sur ce
peuple malheureusement trop mis de côté
dans le jeu voilà j'espère que ces
théories vous auront plus je suis
content d'avoir pu faire une vidéo sur
cette saga dont je suis fan depuis des
années et d'avoir un peu changé de star
wars dont nous parlons très souvent je
suis conscient d'associer beaucoup
breath of the wild à ocarina of time
mais ces jeux possèdent réellement un
énorme lien à mes yeux ce zelda breath
of the world est un jeu qui me fait
rêver qui me fait réellement apprécié le
jeu vidéo et je vous le conseille donc à
tous sur ce on se retrouve pour une
prochaine vidéo théorie merci à ceux qui
mettront un pouce bleus et partageront
la vidéo c'était targon rock que le
liner soit avec vous
[Musique]